Mary nous t'invitons dans notre
cercle si c'est toi éteins les
bougies oh
Seigneur c'est de l'arnaque
elle l'a mérité maman ton travail c'est
de te tenir derrière les rideaux pas
d'attaquer les clients quand à toi jeune
fille c'est quoi de
l'arnaque
[Musique]
c'est pas
normal elle a beaucoup de problèmes rien
de très inquiétant c'est quoi ça un
nouvel accessoire de
travail esprit est-ce que tu m'entends
oui nous
t'entendons et on peut te voir aussi
Doris à qui est-ce que tu
parles papa est-ce que tu es
là tu es qui
vous l'avez vu écrire ça non parce que
c'est du
polonais Doris qui écrit ça je vais te
montrer es-tu
là il se passe des choses qu'on ne peut
pas
comprendre je suis inquiet pour votre
fille le monde des esprits est
dangereux
qu'est-ce que tu fais je fais rien
arê tu sais ce que ça fait un homme
quand on
l'étrangleor estu
bizarre VI est
phénoménal je pense qu'elle canalise des
puissan
nousignorons
souris tu es là est-ce que c'est toi
[Applaudissements]
oui